our patreon recommended that i diagnose
spongebob episode
let's just do nickelodeon and get a
bunch in there see if your favorite
show's reviewed
i'll cater to your every whim until that
leg of yours is entirely
healed i don't know what injury she has
but that's a full leg cast above the
knee i don't know
what injury she had that's not a bad
idea
[Music]
what happened munch housing in full
effect when a patient
pretends to be ill in order to gain
attention and or
sympathy there's actually a munch house
in by proxy where someone can
actively make like their child ill to
get attention and sympathy for the both
of them it's a really devastating
illness because it presents so many
complications like the doctor has to
even suspect that it's potentially
happening what are you gonna do
i'm gonna take pictures of your insides
say cheese
we don't get full body x-rays for a leg
pain there's no point of that it's just
exposing you to more radiation
they're targeted it's kind of strange at
first but after a while
you get to like it when the x-ray tech
or the radiology specialist is in there
with you they actually
start the machine up go behind a wall so
they're protected because otherwise
they're exposed to so much radiation
over the dozens and dozens tests they do
in a given day it's not healthy
we'll be sick forever unless i can
extract some mitochondria from the virus
and make a vaccine
okay medically he just spoke gibberish
getting the mitochondria
the energy center of the cell not the
powerhouse of the cell will not allow
you to create a vaccine if you want to
create a vaccine you create a protein
on the surface of it then you put it
into the body and allow the immune
system to recognize it
you know the way that we traditionally
make vaccines i don't know what he's
talking about
[Music]
look there's coral's brain where i don't
see it
is it behind that walnut on a stick your
brain is a lot bigger than that
i got people inside me why whenever they
do medical procedures on cartoons they
like
scrap people in like it's a torture
device
all right they just traveled into the
stomach so right away if this was to
happen
the acid would melt their little
inflatable raft here
and they would fall into the acid and
lose their lives which is why by the way
drinking alkanized water
is complete horse poop the reason i say
it is because when you drink
the alkalized water that means it has
like a ph of eight instead of seven
it falls into your stomach acid which
has a ph of like two what do you think
happens to the ph of eight when it mixes
with a huge container ph of two
no longer alkaline
well where do next does it the mountains
the arctic
i feel like these are the current
devices we have now you hop on a peloton
and it's like where do you want to ride
through what trail and to me like i
understand a lot of people don't have
time to go outside or the weather's not
cooperative but like folks spend some
time outdoors
it's cool too oh no you need to start
out slow doug
see the important thing is not destrain
yourself
[Music]
amazing advice no joke in a cartoon
right now
i had to just get back into working out
i used to bench like 255 285 during my
workouts the other day i was doing 95
and it's okay
it bruises the ego but it strengthens
the muscles
nothing like a sea nut butter and
jellyfish jelly sandwich ew
peanut butter oh that sounds gross
to help you get to sleep and ideally you
don't
eat too close to bedtime because then
your stomach produces all those gastric
juices highly acidic and then when you
lie down and you're parallel to the
floor and the gastric juices starts
coming up you get heartburn
smelly fridge syndrome
the fridge no lie that's how i sleep i
love it
freezing i like to sleep with multiple
covers with a hoodie on sometimes i
actually just got like one of these
cooling mattresses maybe it's because i
grew up in siberia and i was in my mom's
womb
i was like freezing all the time so i
want to go back to that that's why we
sleep in the fetal position
don't be silly gary i don't get colds
i get the studs no no gary
if i had the suds i'd have bubbles
coming out of me
[Music]
oh no he has the suds grandma was right
to a degree if you go outside and your
hair is wet
or you get a chill it doesn't mean that
you're gonna get sick
it can just make you a little bit more
susceptible than you were before
hey spongebob i'm sick patrick i'm gonna
go ahead and guess that he has a dental
virus because you know he has the
conjunctiva that's inflamed he has the
upper respiratory symptoms i don't know
if he has diarrhea i mean he probably
doesn't have diarrhea because he's a
cartoon sponge after all if a cartoon
sponge was to have diarrhea and inflamed
conjugative
and upper respiratory symptoms
adenovirus i know a guy who
knows a guy who went to the doctor once
and
the doctor's office is a horrible
horrible place
it is not we have fun there
well first they make you sit in the
waiting room is that the horrible part
patrick no
it gets worse they make you read
all magazines i don't know why that is
can we update our magazine collection in
the medical offices for god's sake
who wants to read about people magazine
from 2006.
i mean we know britney was killing it
back then but we want to know what's up
now
is that the year she was killing then
the doctor pulls out his stethoscope
it's a device so sinister so
icy cold when it touches your bear flesh
it
honestly the cold stethoscope is one of
the meanest things a provider can do for
you
every time before i make contact with
the patient's chest and or back to
listen to lungs
i do one of these and i
get some of the warmth of my hand onto
the stethoscope it's the least you can
do for your patients
you gotta help me get better patrick
please
i'm so excited to see what patrick's
about to recommend if he says manuka
honey i might give the starfish a high
five
[Music]
i have been a doctor for like
seven eight years medical school four
years i do not
know what that thing is on patrick's
head that doctors used to wear back in
the day it doesn't make sense
it reflects light i it has a hole in the
middle
i have no idea what it is what it does
i've even worn it as part of a halloween
costume
oh my god i actually look like a doctor
it appears as though we'll have to plug
up these holes
this saw to do the trick
feel better i don't know i'm gonna do a
hyper analysis here see what's happening
is
instead of treating spongebob's core
illness he's treating the symptoms only
if this is a viral illness that's a
perfectly acceptable way of go about it
to allow the immune system time to heal
to rest to improve itself but if it's a
bacterial infection we're missing it
we're treating symptoms
and not treating the underlying cause it
could be a big cause for concern there
patrick my lawyers will be in touch or
as my legal eagle friend says it i'll
see you in court i'll see you
in court
[Music]
feeling better yet not really why'd he
pull out his team
who a boat no
i know i think so actually you may think
this is silly
this is something we sort of do in the
hospitals it's called chest physical
therapy if a patient has a lot of mucus
we actually have specialized beds that
perform this like thumping feature that
helps clear out the mucus in patients
who have cystic fibrosis
we actually need this type of chest
physical therapy to be done on a regular
basis in order to help them expel that
mucus
and prevent blockages in the airways
kind of crazy that spongebob has some
level of medical accuracy
who knew it seems you have the suds are
you ready for your treatment
the doctor's wearing the thing again
what is that thing what is annoying
and why is there a fish anatomy in the
background when there's a sponge
patient different species
well it looks like your gluteus maximus
has made a full recovery oh his gluteus
maximus are using proper anatomical
terms i guess he tore a muscle in his
buttock
your butt's all better it's really quite
amazing i love that they do
an x-ray first of all you can't x-ray a
gluteus maximus you can't x-ray muscles
you can x-ray bones
joints but not muscles it took 20 hours
to put it all back together
we actually ran out of staples and had
to use a glue stick there is a fact here
in closing skin there are both of those
options
for example if you get a cut on your
skull you could actually close it with
staples it works quite well
if you get a small cut on your hand we
have skin glue that can keep it together
it's not cool spongebob what's up
ah doctor thank goodness you're here
they're wearing the thing on their heads
again and what seems to be the problem
today
my throat hurts why is this patient
admitted
inpatient into a hospital for a throat
egg with again
a chart on the bedside that looks like a
stock market chart more than a dozen ekg
what even
is that i'll need one medical c chicken
[Music]
what's a medical situation
hey my keys and my throat feels better
he's not a doctor of humans
he's a vet because they're in a fish
tank
or at the bottom of the ocean and
there's a catfish
that ate some keys and didn't have strep
throat
but had key throat
you saw that one subscribe
[Music]
little laryngitis oh those tonsils are
really enlarged general tonsillitis
i think we should take them out now
we're trying to move away from doing
tonsillectomies we're weighing the risks
versus benefits here and we're we have
like a set of guidelines that we follow
if you have
x number of strep throats or tonsillitis
or pharyngitis
that we get you set up with an ent who
then makes a decision whether or not
they need to come out now we're trying
to do our best to manage it medically
and not have to resort to a surgical
operation if we don't need to that
doesn't mean you won't get surgery
i'm just saying there's options on the
table wow what am i gonna do arnold
maybe if you gargle or something
gargling is actually not a bad option uh
also
honey you know i love my honey are you
having problems with your you know what
no my the giggly gland is fine it is
what gland
no it's not cosmo's for giggling gland
is
for giggly gland i wonder what the [ __ ]
giggly gland is
the special magical organ in a fairy's
body that allows us to
change shape what is cosmo
sex let me put this to you in terms
cosmo could understand
yes why does the doctor keep putting the
glasses on taking them off and why is
the stethoscope floating i need extra
and he's wearing that thing what is that
thing
[Music]
oh no walking dead again
why are they all jaundiced
[Music]
it looks okay
986 degrees 98.6 degrees normal body
temperature
this morning our house became infested
with an acute febrile contagious virus
or as it's known on the street the flu
oh the flu we haven't been seeing much
of that lately with 13 loads packed into
1200 square feet when someone gets sick
it spreads like the plague that's true
actually in like college dorm rooms
military barracks anytime you have
people living in close proximity it's
very easy for one person to get sick
and then get everybody else sick in case
you're attacked this concoction will
slow down the infected what is it
boogers
tastes like chicken soup oh that's
because it is chicken soup
i would be just shooting out of my mouth
all day i love chicken soup
[Music]
they won't let go
[Music]
stop making so much noise it's just a
purple pentapus
oh it's a purple pentapus it's never
heard of a purple pentapus
i don't know why this popped into my
head if you ever heard of molluscum
contain geosum it sounds really serious
but it's
not really that scary of a virus that
causes like these little skin pearly
papules to pop up
it happens more often in kids people who
share towels sometimes they're sexually
transferred
i like when they just like rub them like
that and they just pop right off
[Music]
morgan school good morning class
good morning miss pancreas miss
pancrease
yes bladder that doesn't look like a
bladder that looks like a lemon
can i go to the bathroom and ironic that
the bladder ass to go
you'll have to wait till after roll call
oh my god this is so embarrassing i
remember in like
second or third grade i asked teacher to
go to the bathroom and she said no
and i peed myself in class
someone said like oh what's that liquid
next to your desk i'm like i spilled a
water bottle
thank god my pants dried quickly so
embarrassing i can't believe i'm talking
about it
kids sometimes ask me weird medical
questions click here to check that out
and as always stay happy and